[Musik]
die voraussetzungen für einen
nationalpark wären gut gewesen
im grenzgebiet zwischen graubünden
tessin lebende wildtiere ungestört der
mensch hat sich weitgehend zurückgezogen
auch der wald wächst und wächst und
wächst
das bild einer fotofalle zeigt die
schollen luchse gedeihen
[Musik]
die wölfe werden immer heimischer
neulich streifte sogar der bär durch das
gebiet das für den parc adula auserwählt
war
[Musik]
in den tälern dieses gebiet leben immer
weniger menschen deren wertvolles natur
und kultur erbe würde durch einen
nationalpark erhalten und touristisch
aufgewertet werden
[Musik]
die frage nationalpark ja oder nein
löste im bündner oberland bittere
diskussionen aus
den größten widerstand leistete war das
kleinste dorf im parkgebiet zehn
einwohner
sie hatten erfolg am 27 november 2016
scheiterte der parc adula an die urne
[Musik]
zum mechaniker der fahrerseite bis mit
über 100 stimmen ja wenn der kampf
gewonnen wie erwartet
freude herrscht
die freude verhalten den verlassenen
teil an die dörfer leeren sich so wie
hier in der wall mädel im bündner
oberland diese entwicklung wollte der
bund mit dem balkan dollar stoppen
mit dem negativen entscheid der
betroffenen bergbevölkerung ist das
thema aber nicht vom tisch
fast die hälfte der schweiz besteht aus
sogenannt strukturschwachen regierungen
und für diesel stellt sich dringend die
frage wie weiter
[Musik]
tabea baumgartner ist aus dem unterland
in die wahlen mädel gezogen
das ist so prof deswegen lässt sich das
paar
wir haben noch vor der abstimmung mit
den dreharbeiten begonnen
da gab es noch hoffnung für den parc
adula die junge historikerin stammt aus
burg und für 2015 das center so silva
agricultura sie plant kulturelle
veranstaltungen in der waldschule
akademie avivi an exkursionen und
thementage für schulen und gruppen
ich bin mental an doch sie gebiert wo
fällig sind und wirken und app ist eine
wirkliche zukunft finde ich es anders
wieder wo man eigentlich so viel
wertvolle sachen und head und war schön
wenn man die zukunft mitnehme
ich glaube die region hat das potenzial
zum beispiel sie für andere periphere
regionen in europa oder weltweit
das ja dass die im oberland ihnen noch
sind aber ein schritt voraus will die
sache mit der hand in hand produkt wo
milch und vor dass wir dort verarbeitet
oder verkauft das beste was eigentlich
nicht sie also für mich ist das
zukunftsorientierte stimmen von machen
[Musik]
die kultur ist wegen des geplanten parks
heimgekehrt der romane hat in zürich
geographie studiert und arbeitet nun als
regionalentwickler für den parc adula
die tatsache dass er aus der gegend
stammt die sprache der einheimischen
spricht hilft ihm bei seinem engagement
für den park die auf wenigstens ist eine
farce das ist schon sehr wichtig dass
nicht blöd vorkommen dass katrina wie
die angst vor fremdbestimmung gewisse
doch etwas mehr über blut und das ist
auch die charakteristische stoppt wenn
man weiß was eigentlich immer besser was
in einem gut ist und man hätten wir mit
allem was vor und vorbei grundmann
vermischten aber auch sehr viel sache
und die realität sieht man einfach
klasse
ohne unterstützung von verbunden sieht
gibt es dir die regionen wieder
effektiven
[Musik]
der parc adula hätte er eine fläche von
1200 50 quadratkilometern das entspricht
dem ganzen genfer see und dem ganzen
bodensee und dem ganzen
vierwaldstättersee zusammen er umfasst
17 gemeinden und seine kern zone von 142
quadratkilometer oder 22.000
fußballplätzen das filetstück der kern
zone ist die kreide die höchste
hochebene im ganzen alpenraum kernzonen
das heißt natur pur und das wiederum
heißt für den menschen wandern nur auf
festgelegten faden keine jagd kein
fischen gebe es den park wäre lotto
rheinpark bewohner für ihn eine
unerträgliche aus sicht von park wo im
unterland sehr günstig naturschutz und
bewegungsförderung von der wirtschaft
das geht einfach nicht und das ist nicht
ehrlich und roma scheitert das lied
merken
bestimmt nicht obwohl der alltag für den
schriftsteller vater von drei kindern
und hausmann mehr als dicht ist nimmt er
den kampf gegen das geplante
nationalpark projekt auf dass ich das
schutz forderte aber nicht im eigenen
garten sondern was woanders dass sie
schaum quiz und mit geld und so geht das
ist eine gewisse beruhigung des
schlechten gewissens oder und aber doch
kann man filme wird natur machen für
naturschutz wenn man im garten zum
beispiel mit einer roboter meter das
vielleicht einmal vorhand macht und
reisepass oder aber doch kann jeder
eigentlich beträge die ja mehr gebraucht
und hofen energie vor allem die benzin
mehr und stinkend uns und so weiter und
so fort
naki hatte platzes ist das perfekte
aushängeschild für den nationalpark die
zweifache mutter lebt ihn zu leihen und
betreibt mit ihrem mann agrotourismus
nebst bio bietet sie lama trackings
bergwanderungen und schneeschuhlaufen an
die beiden haben ihre alphütte zu einer
herberge umgebaut
anna frank lemme vom bach kritischsten
echte sie bevormundet fühlt familie groß
und spd heißt plötzlich durch nummern
und denke was immer jetzt doch nein denn
dann hätte ich emotionen weckt aber geil
wenn man danach sucht nachhaltiges leben
und aber so zu leben
das kind wird deutlich wenn es gern sich
in der natur bewegen
denn das von oben herab befohlen
auch tabea baumgartner baut auf den
sanften tourismus und korea gemacht
haben zuversichtlicher bau marke dass
ich jetzt wieder da und wenn andere
immer die schülerzahl an das plakat
gestaltet und jetzt die idee dass man
kriegen wieder den ball zurückbringt und
der kontakt nicht verlieren der natur
dass sie wieder und treffsicher und
lernen wie das funktioniert mit ihrem
fahrrad setzt sich das ziel das man auch
neue touristen erzählt dass man auch ein
gast reduziert wo das interesse hätte
der kultur der region
ich schaue nicht so dass das
nationalpark und berg santana touristen
erzählt sondern es sind sehr oft mit war
gut verdienen hat wage es gebe zwar
bereit sind zum einen die qualität das
heißt eine partie ohne große masse
touristen sondern sie werden ein
interessierter gast war bereit für
qualität zu zahlen
die kultur hat das von der gemeinde
mittel aufgegebene altersheim übernommen
und will daraus ein hotel machen
einige freunde unterstützen ihn dabei
mit geld oder indem sie selbst mit
anpacken
sie investieren über eine million ihr
glaube an die zukunft der park region
ist groß
ich glaube dass man einfach da wie das
schicksal was man da überhaupt nur eine
so sachen kultur kultur
händler sprachen hand mir in der riesige
vielfalt möglich sind aber nicht genau
wir haben im wert setzen wir haben die
nutzer mich am rad der touristisch
buchbar machen dass man damit auch noch
geld verdienen
platz geschaffen das heißt alle die wert
sind oft wendet das vergessen er schätzt
dass von der heimische selber und ja man
merkt dass das wirklich wert hat
darum gewisser stolz zeigt dass man die
werte und daran glaubt den rahmen die
umwelt hätte ohne das man muss voll crs
machen sondern dass man die friedliche
welt sind einen monat vor der abstimmung
kommt es in falls bei einer
infoveranstaltung zu einem stimmungstest
die park promotoren sowie beamte des
kantons sind angereist mit dem ziel die
zweifel der falsche zu zerstreuen
im nationalpark der sogenannten neuen
generation leben und produzieren die
einheimischen im einklang mit der natur
[Musik]
ein parklabel fordert die vermarktung
ihre produkte
[Musik]
mit versteinerten mienen verfolgten die
fall sei das zukunftsversprechen des
werbefilms nicht einmal die vom bund in
aussicht gestellten arbeitsplätze und
fördergelder weichen sie auf
[Musik]
nach dem film eisiges schweigen wie vor
umweltschutz organisationen unterstützen
der park hauptsächlich weg da kennt
sondern dass dieser großartige natur
sowie dekan chrissi bereich druck
geraten
die umgebungs zone wird vom gesetz nicht
ändern
das heißt wir ihn nicht mehr
möglichkeiten zum in flussnähe wir
finden der praktische chance für die 17
für die nachhaltige langfristige
entwicklung dankeschön
während vom wwf präsident der
unterstützer der bank a dollar und mehr
der parc adula unterstütze oder an dem
moment unterstützen werte wwf wo gemacht
danke
[Musik]
der kritische stimmen aus dass ein dass
es kritische stimmen
das thema ist also mit anständiger und
[Musik]
immer über die
dieser vorfall seitens der bi und kurz
vor der kampagne hand ist machbar ist
und was sagt und dann kommt der zug kurz
und bündig mit uns ganz zu rechnen wie
der roman ist das nicht so parente die
meinung geändert oder rang acht kam
einig und das finde ich schrecklich wenn
man nicht ja oder nein sagen kann oder
will dass ich schon abstimmen kann man
etwa ein zeiger und bekannte im größten
architekt vor der literatur und vom
himmel und vertrauen das mir der woche
kaum einer kennt
an der erfahrene noch aus
[Musik]
im winzigen laden den die mittel zu
bauen an der paßstraße führen verkauft
tabea baumgartner alles was das tal hier
gibt der laden läuft gut
einheimische wie durch reisende schätzen
die lokal und produkte vordergründig ist
ihr nichts zu spüren von den problemen
der region schwache konjunktur und
bevölkerungsschwund nicht spüre eine
resignation jetzt gerade bei uns im dorf
fischmann situation bank vorzuweisen die
torflaute vita gartner weist uhr wird
sogar auf die andere seite standen sieht
das paar junge leute aktiv wo nicht
spüre meine energie und meine ist wie
der sender da wo bewegungen ist also es
gibt für mich beides nicht nur die natur
sondern auch die kultur ist dir wichtig
hier wird tabea baumgartner für ihr
kinoprogramm
sie zeigt vorwiegend filme über kultur
und umwelt in den alten es geht das auch
wofür langsam gehen zum beispiel und
denn dann kann man es braucht so viel
geduld es braucht und
nadja der platzes tat sich anfänglich
schwer mit dem gedanken eine bergbau in
in einem nationalpark zu sein
nicht zuletzt wegen ihrer lamas aktiv
sind erlaubt aber am anfang sind die
packt ihr spezifisches und russland
wünscht
relativiert wird so allgemein packt ihr
das nicht einfach und mit wem und
dänisches glaubt so erlaubt mit in
zusammenhang mit der hütte versorgung ja
so als grund das genauso mit gericht
nicht folgen
weiß nicht sie integrieren und so sich
nicht so das bild vom bündner oberland
lama sucht auch und die einzeln war
damit aber wie ich jetzt mittlerweile
mit dem einscannen sich typische sie
waren überhaupt
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
in seinem kampf gegen den nationalpark
setzt leo tuor auch seine literatur ein
eine passage aus seinem erfolgreichen
erstlings jörg umberg klingt dann so die
städte haben ihre lebensräume zerstört
gibt ihnen das ein recht auf die unseren
unserer beiden sollen wüsten ein werden
unsere wälder einwachsen und wir sollen
ihre amerikaner seien haderlumpen
rohkost rast macht eure parks in euren
städten nichts liegt uns an der zukunft
die ihr uns bereiten wird
geht zum kuckuck mit euren ratschläge
respektiert uns die wir hier nicht in
den ferien sind
wieso immer das bestimme wähler was gut
für die bälle risch warum das das ist ja
respektlosigkeit behaupte es gehe um
partikularinteressen
das ist doch nicht was gut und böse
israel seit über 30 jahren kommt leo
tour in die kleine hütte nach carpet in
den ersten jahren als hirte später als
jäger mir lebend da und mir endlich das
mir and miri nicht kampflos struktur
wieder steht mirena kulturbetrieb
widersteht gehen und die anderen zittern
und so fort mir hängt aber eine relativ
gut bewertet und die ergebnisse und den
dass man die enorme hand ist der
sternenhimmel und der steiermark nies
das jagdgebiet von carpet wurde von den
park promotoren im verlauf der
verhandlungen aus der kern zone
ausgeschlossen
sollten sie dies in der absicht getan
haben leere tor für den park einzunehmen
weit gefehlt
entscheidend für leo torres haltung ist
die greiner hochebene besondere
landschaft widerwillige klebt an willi
das geld von den village of tötet
anbietet - die freundin an - die
freundschaften auch mit männern und und
das ist ein stück heimat für mich heimat
solidarität oder die solidarität wo
wohnen würde im kampf für die kleinen
kunden mit mit mit den umweltverbänden
in den 80er jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts erschraken einheimische wie
unterländer über einen staudamm projekt
das die einzigartige landschaft zu
zerstören drohte
leo tour war damals hielt auf der
krainer und engagierte sich gegen den
staudamm mit erfolg 1986 wurde die
kleiner ebene ins bundesinventar der
landschaften und naturdenkmäler von
nationaler bedeutung aufgenommen
es war ein paradigmenwechsel der erhalt
einer landschaft wo schwerer als der
profit und sein sieg mit bitterem
beigeschmack
populär wurde dort aber dass die ganze
woche strömt und keine jetzt verfolgen
im überfluss
diese ist es schlimmer wenn so engagiert
durch wasser überflutet wird oder durch
tourismus jeweils einem das bessere 2003
erklärte der bund die krainer auch noch
zum wild asyl
damit verlor leo tour sein liebstes
jagdgebiet traurige gefühle mir wenn ihr
den arm amputiert wurden wir haben da
keine anderen entscheid erwartet die
alle zehn sterne gemerkt die sehnsucht
nach unberührten landschaften entsteht
in den städten
hier macht man sich auch am meisten
gedanken darüber wie sich der alpenraum
entwickeln soll
aktuell sind projekte für pärke gelb
biosphärenreservate braun naturerlebnis
berggruen regionale naturpärke von
nationaler bedeutung
und rot nationalparke
[Musik]
wenn man jetzt das verglichen mit der
nachbarländer strichen und frankreich
die vier filme berg nordschweiz die
entries feuer gefangen
mit dem mit der bürgschaft wieder
ländlichen und das funktioniert zu
schaffen und das haben jetzt so gemacht
natürlich andere instrumente ganz stark
der finanzausgleich kam in der
agrarpolitik kann wo man die
bergregionen haie-trainer igor alter und
somit ist vielleicht das instrument pack
der schweiz langsame zu wichtig sie und
dass das trotzdem braucht und jetzt sind
eigentlich relativ wenig nutzt man dass
man nutzt darf er nur der folglich und
ja es ist es gibt eine akquise
konkurrent der schweiz selber zwischen
einer ländlichen region und muss mit
berg entsteht sicher besser da als die
etwas versteckt allen parks gemein ist
den erschöpften städtern erholung und
den einheimischen ein auskommen zu
verschaffen
so funktioniert es auch mit nadia die
platzes lama trekking entscheidend ist
wirtschaftlich annika und dick sein das
ist jetzt momentan in der zeitspanne
woman könnt überblick des inhalts und
machen nicht nur wissen sich enthält
einfach machen
sie könnte sie rechnete sie hat ja dass
sie halte das land bewegt darf
bewirtschaftet
das wird so die erkenntnis dass dir
nicht verloren galten scharfe sachen
sind schon verloren gegangen und
vielleicht angebracht so sachen versucht
sich halten
eigentlich ein wirtschaftliches im juni
trainieren
aber das führt in die nachkommen die
welt hat sich nach alter werden
naja des platzes ist überzeugt wir in
den bergen leben will findet einen weg
in der soße wahre leben weiterhin bauern
aber sie sind zu wenige um den
bevölkerungsschwund aufzuhalten
wichtige es diesbezüglich das gewerbe
und so überrascht es nicht dass sie
diesem sektor die vehementesten
verfechter für den parc adula
anzutreffen sind kurden meisten für den
thron eine schweinerei mit 50
mitarbeitern
er sieht im park eine einzigartige
chance für die region
die genutzte ganz machen über die grenze
geschafft
vor allem so tourismus läuft sehr sehr
wenig was stadt nicht trüben könnte zu
unterland 1 10 50 oder im unterland wenn
doch nicht los dass die am morgen zu
kümmern
das leben kann und der innovations- das
volumen zum renovieren ist gewaltig
konkret er haft sich kurden meisten das
mit dem nationalpark mehr leute aus dem
unterland in die gegend kommen und
leerstehende häuser und wohnungen kaufen
[Musik]
die arbeit in der schreinerei nimmt seit
der annahme der zweitwohnung initiative
jahr um jahr ab
wenn man ihn in unserem gebiet kann man
soviel quadratkilometer berglandschaft
naturlandschaft hat eine breite ist so
einen ganz kleinen teil
wenn sie mal um falschen ort und radio
lora gemeinsam mit fünf kilometer kein
sondergebiet einen ort wo noch mal eine
entscheidende ich nicht dass man die
probleme zu finden scheint
[Musik]
eine woche vor der abstimmung kommt es
zwischen gegnern und anhängern im
romanischen fernsehen zur großen
schlussdebatte
[Musik]
die kultur ist bereit
leo tour lässt auf sich warten
der moderator erklärt schon mal die
spielregeln seiner kommt kommt dir wenn
nicht fangen wir an
es ist eine live sendung
und wie ist diese taktik die weißen
bären
[Musik]
zwei minuten vor sendebeginn auftritt
leere tor
[Musik]
es ist auswärts gorbatschow und jetzt
der spezial präsenz verehrte anwesende
es gibt in den alpen hunderte schöne
täler und wir wollen uns mit unseren
tellern positionieren damit man sie
sieht und kennt das heißt die
sichtbarkeit ist eines der starken
argumente für einen park 17 gemeinden
zusammen sind auf jeden fall stärker als
jede für sich allein keine fantasie
haben und auch funktionäre hören wenn
geld kommt gibt keine impulse das können
wir vergessen
simply da jeder seine marke es gebe eine
marke sichtbarkeit geld für projekte und
arbeitsplätze und was wir dafür aufgeben
müssen nicht kaputt gemacht sondern
geschützt
hört mit diesem marketing auf die etwas
ist braucht keine markt nur ein nobody
braucht ein label wenn wir den
bevölkerungsschwund aufhalten wollen
brauchen wir kinder keine berge
das ist einfach so und in einem
nationalpark schaut pro natura mit
argusaugen auf jede kleinigkeit die wir
machen das ist so wir haben
unglaublichen bereits drei regionalwerk
wo das gleiche gilt bis heute gibt es
nicht einen protest von seiten der
umweltschutzverbände der sich auf die
park verordnung bezieht kommt dazu wir
haben in der charta die klausel dass
wenn eine gemeinde nach zehn jahren
nicht mehr ja sagt zu einer zweiten park
phase die restriktiven elemente der kern
zone automatisch aufgelöst werden oder
dass mit den zehn jahren ist ein
wer heiratet schon vor zehn jahren viele
heutzutage
ich kenne niemanden der gesagt hatte er
würde für zehn jahre heiraten
gratifikation affinen die der
kostenseite
die stadt war in aktion
[Applaus]
[Musik]
viele argumente gegen sind immer die
gleichen argument
naturschutzorganisationen der welt
strahlen sicherheit für die bevölkerung
begegnet und das ist etwas mehr die
meinung fällt also das was dir
befürwortet auch positivste lieblinge
positiven erträge bringen
sie bringen das engagement nicht mehr
gespielt fertig
[Musik]
wie es kam dass die sparkasse spitze
schob sie aber das ist schon gut
agierende schauberg zu tags mach mal
selber mal verstehen hält sind so
wichtig hinter mir als ob der
amerikanische das monatlich ja einiges
an leo denkt hat im fermi steht
eigentlich vom gesundheitswesen über
agrarpolitik über weite recht für mich
der eigentlich alles mit dem park und
der park ridge und dass das alles
schlecht ist und das in ein fahles
unabhängig vom nein zu den park laufen
die sachen so vitalisiert sind und
polizei wurzeln wohl weniger gut sind
aber mit dem parkett
die spielt gerne die befürworterinnen
die oberste weltuntergang prophezeit auf
als der park nie käme und ihm eine
wahlkampf kurz mit das akzeptiere ich
meinen wahlkampf kurz um emotionen und
dort sehr stark um emotion ist unseriös
wird man philosophisch seeger üben um
events oder und austria das ist es in
ihrer das ist es existenziell das
territorium wo man wohnt und wo man lebt
und wer stirbt und das lot man sich
nicht einfach nicht so schnell
wenn sie mich warum halbe york fragte
was passiert wenn ich weg bin für mich
ist gerade so wie es jetzt ist vitamin
apathisch wir die stelle ist wenn ich an
ist spannend wenn die panik und die
schnitt klar ob das so weitergeht und
denn heute findet dann bin ich weg
aber ich glaube da inzwischen und haben
im freundeskreis auto ja und das ist
wenn ist einfach zum sage dann bin ich
weg also die show direkt unsererseits
gewachsen
und ja also ich an ihm abschließend
sagen wenn der park nickel und bin ich
sicher weg das ist
16 jahre haben die vorbereitungen für
diese abstimmung gedauert
zehn millionen haben sie gekostet am 27
november 2016 findet der urnengang statt
die wahlbeteiligung ist sie hoch die
kultur ist im stall eines freundes als
die ersten resultate ein treffen sie
verheißen nichts gutes
er gibt sich tapfer
kurz nach mittag zeichnet sich ab der
parc adula wird nicht durchkommen
natürlich ein platz frei ist ein leben
ja während der kampf krone wie erwartet
freude herrscht die pläne für einen
neuen nationalpark sind definitiv
gescheitert
nur acht von 17 tessiner und bündner
gemeinden wollen beim parc adula
mitmachen 13 gemeinden wären nötig
gewesen
die kam zone des parks wäre 145
quadratkilometer groß geworden
im romanischen fernsehen kommentiert
sp-nationalrätin silva semadeni
präsidentin von pro natura das ergebnis
die leute haben die wichtigkeit dieser
historischen chance
drei gebirgsregionen gemeinsam zu
entwickeln nicht verstanden
nun stehen sie ohne perspektive da
steckt nie was sie nicht
und was soll ich mir flügen in zürich
erzähler jetzt erwartet denker
verzeichnet sie deiner freunde mehr
kümmern und auch nicht nach zürich aber
nun zeigen was mit dem zürichsee zum
beispiels passiert
er lügt während das an ort und stelle
entscheiden der bundesrat leuenberger
ritter show 2000 rückseite dass dialekte
der berge nicht immer eine reserve rennt
man hat wieder nach einer strategie
geändert wie dann noch einmal probiert
in ihn in lokal asse jetzt da jetzt sind
national berg in der schweiz
verschiedene endgültig begraben und die
anderen teil schwerer stand
[Musik]
das ist unser bündnis motor wird von
rechten und linken der betroffenen
gemeinden gleichermaßen beglückwünscht
es ist eine unheilige allianz die den
parc adula verhindert hat
[Musik]
[Applaus]
fragt ob vielen dank ihr habt ihr
abgestimmt
ich glaube das thema park ist endgültig
vom parkett und dass er eigentlich
dieses ziels sie jetzt wird sofort
natürlich seid ihr jetzt zeigen was ihr
könnt und mir vor rund 15 millionen und
den zeigen analyt was wir können
[Applaus]
wie das sprichwörtliche zeitgeist glaub
das ist und wie es wie man politik macht
das ist sehr polemisch man versucht vor
unsicher immer versucht vor allem
vermisst vor allem ganz viel themen aber
mit den angaben zum die eigenen ziele zu
erreichen und das ist ja nicht mehr
gesehen dass auf der ganzen welt wie ihr
das momentan läuft und ich denke sich im
kleinen das beispiel der fiel am tag
danach sprechen die schweizer medien von
einer verpassten chance die
umweltministerin außer sich am radio
sicher kann ich die ganze schweiz 200
parklandschaft verkommen aber ich
persönlich denke auch die region hat
sich eine chance vergeben aber das ist
zu respektieren
[Musik]
also für mich innerlich sie aber die
polemik wurde ein riss entstanden ist
direkt nicht umbaut sich durch das gibt
dir einen ganz klaren haltung ja wenig
chemie studiert und machen was sie will
ich mache was sie will und hätten mit
dem park das gemacht haben ihre trainer
es gibt auch nebeltage und honig
das argument sie das ist das ist ihm
gelungen
nach die abstimmung ist wieder ruhe
eingekehrt im oberland wir treffen leo
tuor vor seiner hütte auf capello war 12
und so leo tuor vertraut uns an dass
sein kampf gegen den park auch mit
seiner geliebten jagd zu tun hat nämlich
damit dass der bund die greiner zum
wildschutzgebiet erklärt hatte ja mit
dem mittag war das ist ein alibi bis sie
wieder katholischen alibi xe firmiert
ist mit der natur das nützt uhr und da
will dass sie lieder greiner die
studentin anna liebig sie will
während der dreieinhalb games pro saison
schossen in das sind alte böcke sie also
der suff der bestand der zionismus
gemacht ja der trend jetzt im winter
genau gleich und wie so oft liegt sie
dagegen nicht ein jäger oder zwei jäger
das verleitet nicht aber den 20 bis 30
touristen
jeden sommer die sonne näher begriff
immer wenn's nicht so gut mit uns meint
moment liegt weiß respektieren
es sind die menschen sind der schritt
mit dem bündnis sogar und irgendein
größte stolz und die bruch und khalid wo
ihnen sagen wir sitzt du hinter der
adler chart
[Musik]
position vor der
umweltschutzorganisation gespielt
ich behaupte dass wir eigentlich da sind
dass die praktikums umgehen will nach
rang 16 portatour schieber hat dass die
eine gültig sind und dass man da strenge
restriktionen wir sie machen den händen
die heimischen ofen heizen abgestimmt
und natürlich wer glaubt dass man mit
dem brachte fast gleich daneben braucht
[Musik]
aber nach die abstimmung ist bekanntlich
vor der abstimmung
und so hofft kurdin meisten bereits auf
sein nächstes projekt ein großer badesee
am rhein mit dem klingenden namens ali
chinas
das lässt sich nicht auch noch fertig
hotelimmobilie rettung oder held von
brachliegenden die bilder verraten hieß
es
sind sie zuversichtlich dass das wohl
wenn man daran glaubt dass wir hoffen
wir sind auf gutem weg kanton hat
sowieso man ihn verstehen wenn es dann
nicht wenigstens probiert aber
realisiert mit speed aber wenig ich
jetzt wirklich löschen zu setzen was
nicht so viele diskussionen auch die
kultur und macht weiter er hat sein
hotel eröffnet und bereits viele gäste
die touristischen angebote die er für
den nationalpark ausarbeitete
funktionieren auch so er ist zufrieden
öffentlich sehen ist auch die hitzige
diskussion sich am schluss aus licht
tauchen und chemie energie scruz oder
der art wenn man miteinander gehabt aber
eigentlich auch über die 5 687 und
dadurch so sehr wach mit allen
persönlich mit dem heimischen computer
und das internet
das heißt mit öffentlicher auftritt ist
man recht schroff aufeinander los aber
nach einem mann dann geschüttelt und
wieder ein licht gibt es sind zwei liter
und das ist immer gut an und ich habe
mich persönlich sehr verstrickt den
mittelpunkt
da solche systeme liegt also wer ihn
sehen dass eine dusche und schicksal
abwenden endliche gestiegen auch da
stehe ich aber inzwischen ist wirklich
sehr schnell
sie spazieren und ich sie ein bisschen
aufrufen sich so lange immer hin und her
diskutiert wurde an irgendwelchen tricks
events einfach ja mit deine ja das ist
einfach dass man immer muss ist dass
jeder mitmachen
trotz des neins zum park 2016 stieg die
zahl der einwohner von mittel von 383
auf 387
für ihren dorfladen fanden die mädels
einen neuen betreiber und für tabea
baumgartners projekte sind neue
geldgeber in sicht spannend ist und
sache geht's zum realisieren
solange ich mich wohlfühle mitglied oder
sind es ist spannend zu lang bin ich
gerne und im moment ja dass du mir dass
man dies betrifft und lokal und
erfahrung mit sprachlich und desto das
zulässige wird es eigene das für immer
das weiß ich nicht aber das ist im
moment genieße ich sehr und bin
zuversichtlich dass es noch so will sie
die nächste titel der parc adula ist
geschichte aber die frage bleibt wie
weiter im alpenraum
bereits im kommenden frühling steht die
nächste entscheidung an
dann stimmt die tessiner bevölkerung
darüber ab ob sie einen nationalpark
will oder nicht
[Musik]